[Music]
did you know that the very first
assembly of photographs to create a
motion picture was a two second clip of
a black man on a horse
and that man is my
great great grandfather great there's
another great grandfather
[Music]
but that's why back at the haywood ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in hollywood we like to say since the
moment pitchers could move
yeah skin of the game
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
it's a bad miracle
[Applause]
we got word for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're still trying to figure out what
happened
[Music]
when did you last hear from her
[Music]
she left to bring her to school
is everything okay
has she gone missing before
not in a long time
mom
i heard about your mom is she all right
it doesn't feel right
i think we should go away just two of us
think you should take it easy at the
moment
mom
where did you go
i can't tell you
not yet
are you awake
what's wrong with you
there's things i need to tell you sure
it's not your mother up there
if we don't do something we'll never get
her back
and then they'll try to take you
dance with me sure
ma'am stop
where's your mom
[Applause]
hmm
this isn't funny amber would you like to
play a game tara
[Laughter]
doors unlocked
all doors locked
doors unlocked
uh
hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
samantha
i'm i know who you are i've been through
this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is gonna keep coming for
you
[Music]
are you ready
for this
never
stop
there's certain rules to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
hello sydney
it's an honor
[Music]
hello hi this is marlo yes
harper yes dude come in
the words i have to say it's a beautiful
house
will it just be you staying
excuse me mrs muller no
until you give your love
there's nothing more that we can do
happen from the garden
yeah it was delicious no no
mustn't do that
forbidden fruit oh
god sorry i i'm drinking
you're tormented
it feels more like
haunted
yeah
something happened
my husband
went upstairs to our balcony
and let himself go
you must wonder why you drove him to it
i didn't drive him to it
i could be true
but if you'd given him the chance to
apologize
he'd still be alive
what
a man he followed me out of the woods
he was stalking me what makes you say
that i saw him twice
twice
i don't know if he saw you once
i'll play a game
you hide
i'll see
you must feel an awful sense
stay away from me
[Music]
daddy
what's going on sweetie
something feels weird
something's changing you remember the
tools you type right
pencil
desk paper ships you're weird everything
okay charlie
it happened again what happened to that
thing if you ever start to lose control
what do you do it didn't work
she's not a robot and he's a little girl
with little girls emotions which are
wildly unpredictable
charlie she just has to shove it down
and keep it hidden
our responsibility is getting her ready
our responsibility is to protect her
charlie
if they catch her they're gonna put her
in a cage charlie they're gonna run
tests on her for the rest of her life
i'll never see her again
if who catches me
something's happened i need it handled
with discretion
and i need her back alive holy [ __ ]
do you know what it means to be on the
run bad men are after us really bad i
hate living like this
you're special charlie i'm not special
i'm a monster
i'm going to help her you want to use
her
charlie don't be stupid
do you feel that let her go or it's
gonna get a lot worse
take the first different kind
a real life
superhero
you need to understand how to use it it
can't be a reaction it's gonna be a
decision
that's the only way that you control it
she's becoming a young woman i'm not
going to jail and someday
soon you're gonna change the world
she may be capable of a nuclear
explosion
on your knees simply with the force of
her mind
who
trust me charlie
you don't have to be afraid
please i can help you liar liar
pants on fire
i don't want to hurt anyone
but it feels kind of good
i'll be home in the morning where are
you going i'm staying over at susie's
tonight
what's new
the flyer
the papers call him the grabber i wish
one combat you don't actually believe
that story do you because he can't hear
you and he doesn't really take kids that
say
oh
beautiful isn't that just peachy cute
you need some help you see that
would you hand me my hat
yes sir
i
am a part-time magician
are those type of loans in there
would you like to see a magic trick
i have an announcement to make one of
our students finney blake was abducted
what if i could help the police find
penny
[Applause]
[Music]
does it work
not since i was a kid
i'll scream i'll scratch your face
this face
daddy i had a dream about it what
happened in your dream he was taken by a
man with black balloons yes we never
release those details
[Music]
please please let the dreams be real see
the wall in front of you i tore a long
cable loose from down there
there's a combination lock on the inside
of the storm door what's the combination
i carved it in the wall
[Music]
you raise the phone step back and swing
look what you made me do
please hurry you remember what i told
you
there's someday i should stand up for
myself someday it's today fan
hahaha
happy dancers
[Music]
[Music]
happy dancers
[Music]
happy dance
[Music]
uh
happy dance
[Music]
mom
what is this
we need more colonies
but that's a lot more work there's
nothing the two of us can't handle
together
[Music]
your life is so retro do you even have a
phone no so how do you talk to your
friends my mom is my friend
[Music]
stop
turn it off
[Music]
what's in the
suitcase what's going on
i'm fine i'm just worried about you i
said i'm fine
who is this woman that's my um
that was all she had
[Applause]
i remember so much
screaming
i didn't want you to know her
why
some koreans believe that life's
hardships are caused by the tormented
spirits of their
you ancestors i think there's something
wrong
it's what you want a final resting place
[Music]
come here
what else have you been lying to me
about
all of this is for you i can't wait to
leave
[Music]
you're not going anywhere
a must here
farmer's daughter take one
i need to be famous wayne
all the best people are ain't nobody
else out there like you
you know why
because you got that x factor
our days of struggling may soon be over
hollywood here we go
this is it our own studio background
i'm looking for a place to stay
oh yes sir
that's one ugly song [ __ ]
and my wife pearl was next door so i
would appreciate a little discretion
you don't know what we're doing does he
well it's better to beg for forgiveness
and ask for permission
would you like to
come
inside my surprise
i want to be in the movie well you can't
the story can't just change midway
through
if daddy catches us
there's no telling what he might do
my wife is not well
it happens after darkness
[Music]
you don't want to leave do you people's
eyes are going to pop out of their damn
skulls when i see this
what
are you all right
now
the boys found this inside what do you
think is on it
i see one goddamn [ __ ] up horror
picture
mum
i'm going now
love you
i love you back
how are things
keeping busier
it's been a difficult year
and the pressure these girls are getting
from all sides
you can beat
anything you're my special girl pets
this this story
about a beautiful young woman
she's perfect in every way
except one thing
[Music]
she never eats
[Music]
this begins to gnaw at the mother
my body sometimes
just
shuts off get nauseous around foods
[Music]
you're unwell we'll figure this out okay
i can feel something inside of me
i've been chosen
you're very good mother
do not infect this family with your
ideas
this is getting seriously out of
control are you suggesting betsy's been
possessed by a demon
quite the opposite
i believe betsy's possessed this family
you
most of all
it's not a game betsy
[Music]
i just want it
all to be over
[Music]
[Music]
last name first name lauren jasmine guys
she got the room
legends
ancestor college is crowded with them
when you go to a school that's nearly as
old as the country you can expect to
hear a few
it can be really hard for students of
color just know i'm here
it's amazing
first black master very exciting it is
[Music]
so you live here too
yeah
[Music]
the whole school is cursed okay you're
gonna have to try a lot harder than that
seriously it's it's real
i understand
i went through it
can i just
this school is unwilling to see itself
for what it truly is
[Music]
i've been having nightmares
you look like you've seen a ghost
[Music]
why is this administration spending more
energy undermining my tenure
than unferreting up he's been
terrorizing the student body
you can't get away from it jasmine
[Music]
it'll follow you
[Music]
it's everywhere
[Music]
we've been gifted this beautiful house
we live here
can you believe it
[Music]
they've wanted to keep the place in your
family jamie
we really appreciate the house
well then you know
it's got a hole in the roof the wheels
they'll do a good job
jamie
you just carry on with your day as if we
weren't here
there is one thing i need to show you
and it's a little bit
peculiar every evening before sunset
she'd leave a blood offering here sorry
did you say blood
for who
for the red caps
[Music]
they'll need feeding
you'll be hungry
can i get in my own house please you
won't idea how many times have the
english come to this country and told us
what areas is now theirs
they need to know their place
what did you leave out tonight oh shoot
you can't miss a single day
hello
is anyone there
i can't be scared i'm not in my own
house
don't leave your wrists alone with the
lads
[Music]
we just came here for some peace
oh
hmm
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
because you know me
[Music]
the women in our parents generation they
just they were more into femininity you
know what i mean
because i think you would just look
great in a dress
but i mean if you were pretty much done
actually thank you if it's cool i'm just
going to snag these leftovers
i don't even know how you do it money
do it dating people
no no you do not need a man okay
so don't play the games just be you
straight out the gate
do you live around here
because i live on aisle six
that was terrible
it was kind of terrible
what's his instagram i want to stalk a
little bit you just have one say what
yeah oh no see that's
that's shady let's play a game tell me
something you don't want me to know i
hate this okay i put all our hopes of
finding happiness through someone else
yeah
girl you all digmatized and i haven't
even seen this dude
what's going on i'm gonna tell you what
you're gonna freak out
no this isn't happening
yeah it's happening
no games than what you wanted
it's about giving
giving yourself over to somebody
[Music]
becoming one forever
that's love
it's a straight girl's fantasy come true
right
[Music]
hello
yes
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but the cure
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
now i face a choice is a hunt
and consume blood
or die
we all have monsters within us
it's up to us to control it
what if i can't
michael morbius
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
more bs
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april 1st
foo fighters you gotta get me a record
it's our tenth album we gotta break the
mold on this one
let's go somewhere we've never been
[Applause]
this place is amazing
do you guys get this overwhelming sense
of death
doesn't really seem like the right fit
whoa
that was weird the sound of this house
is the sound of album 10.
all right you guys amps living room let
me apologize in advance for all the rock
we're about to make
got a couple of ideas i've been working
on i'll lay them on you
[Music]
dude wait no
it's called everlong and you wrote it
about 20 years ago
how you feeling everything okay ever
since we moved into this house
my mind is flooded
we all have writer's block this is not
just a creepy rock and roll house
it allows spiritual entities to cross
into our world
oh my god
dude has got one flew over the cuckoo's
nest crazy
it's this place man
let's finish the track can we just wait
dude
you found a new musical note oh yes i
did it's an owl
any chefs in the group i'm pretty handy
on the grill
yeah you like your meat charred and
dried
he does make a killer barbecue
what do we do
[Music]
is the album almost done yeah it's
killer
there you go man finish the song
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]